bridgerton fans get ready to meet the
new leading lady in town
you may recognize simone ashley from sex
education
but how will her role in bridgerton
break conventions both on screen
and in her personal life as much as we
adored following the courtship and love
story of the dreamy duke of hastings and
daphne bridgerton
we're eager to see the new hottest
couple in town take over
the introduction of 25 year old actress
simone ashley as kate sharma
is bound to rock the bridgerton world
and bring forth all sorts of steamy
romance
enticing drama and scandalous scenes
here's what we know about how this new
leading lady will change the bridgerton
series as we know it
season 2 will be following lord
anthony's journey to find love
hugh kate sharma the debutant newly
arrived in london from india
who is described as a smart headstrong
young woman who suffers
no fools really watch out anthony
from first impressions we're pretty
confident he's met his match in simone
ashley
one of the major differences between the
book and the series is kate's background
in the book her name is kate sheffield
whereas in the series she will be named
kate sharma
to reflect the fact that she's of indian
descent with ashley's introduction to
the series comes a new central plot and
a couple for us to fall
in love with according to jonathan
bailey the new season will be more
exciting
convoluted sexy and will be pushing
boundaries
there's a k out there for everyone let's
put it that way
simone ashley is certainly no stranger
to breaking conventions
and we're anticipating seeing lots of
that on screen in bridgerton
a central way the show will continue to
push boundaries is by breaking
conventions of race
casting a south asian woman to play a
south asian character in this leading
role
is significant not only for a show set
in the regency era but for any western
tv show
season 1 already showed us a lot of
diverse casting on screen
with golda rushevel as queen charlotte
and of course reggae jean-page as simon
bassett
adding simone ashley to the mix furthers
the diverse representation we'll get to
see on screen
in ashley's personal life breaking
conventions has been part of her daily
life since she was a young girl
the actor grew up in a family filled
with indian academics with whom she's
very very close
sometimes a bit too close you're so
picky mum
ashley has said that her parents were a
bit stifling at times because they were
so overprotective of her
though it was all out of love however
considering all of this
it means that her choice to be an actor
was not a small decision welcomed with
open arms or approached lightly
ashley has said that it made her family
very nervous when she wanted to pursue a
career in the arts due to the
uncertainty and precarity of the
industry
despite their worries and reservations
ashley knew creativity was her calling
and chose to take the leap
despite the unpredictable lifestyle she
knew she would be facing
even now she still has to reassure her
family that she will be okay
though maybe she won't need to as much
after this
major casting announcement we're glad
she followed her creative instincts
ashley wanted to break the mold and
rebel against indian stereotypes
a pursuit she has definitely succeeded
at
we know that she will be jonathan
bailey's love interest on screen in
bridgerton but this actually isn't the
first time they'll be sharing the screen
the two appeared in the british serial
crime drama broadchurch
a few years ago while this is simone
ashley's first major leading role
she is no stranger to the netflix screen
having appeared in the hit show sex
education
as the frustrated mean girl olivia your
bag's fake
your mascara is clumpy you'll never have
the right body type to get a proper
thigh gap she's also acted alongside
some pretty big names like ryan reynolds
in the movie pokemon detective pikachu
yeah pika pika pika he's adorable
you're adorable she's also appeared on
the bbc show's casualty and doctors
so what does this actress love
i don't want to get in trouble well
she's a big rock and roll fan and has
listed fleetwood mac
the doors and the rolling stones as some
of her favorite bands
this love for music was definitely
inspired by her father who is both an
academic and a creative
ashley once said that her father was
very passionate about music photography
and film always having music playing
while she was growing up
from what we've gathered from her
instagram she seems to be a
huge animal lover and foodie as well we
were also delighted
to see the photos she posted with her
sex education cast mates
hopefully she'll be sharing plenty of
bridgeton content as well
if we weren't already looking forward to
season 2 dropping we definitely are now
simone ashley feels like the perfect
addition to the bridgeton series
even co-star jonathan bailey and writer
of the books julia quinn
agree
[Music]
you